allez viens
j'ai la danse une couille dans les
veines ouais dans les veines
[Musique]
c'est pour le concours
on se laisse pas déstabiliser
faut absolument que cette petite nénée
entre dans l'école
vous êtes le directeur de l'opéra mais
je suis la directrice de l'école de
danse
[Applaudissements]
va être bien non mais dans ce c'est pas
un métier c'est une chance pour elle il
faut de la persévérance de la santé et
de la chance
pour tourne
tu arrives pas romane voilà
tu continues à poser autant de problèmes
tu ne vas pas faire long feu chez nous
j'ai plus envie papa je vais arrêter la
danse si tu doutes ma fille
je mériterais d'avoir le rôle de
Blanche-Neige une danseuse doit
apprendre à gérer ses frustrations
[Musique]